good evening thanks for coming out
tonight
my name is Malika I'm a bookseller here
at the store and on behalf of the owners
and the staff I'd like to welcome you to
politics and prose it's a pleasure to
have Michael uborrow with us tonight
who's written an extensive biography of
Senator Pat McCarran Democrat from
Nevada who presided in Congress for
twenty years until his death in 1954
it's not only to study why Washington
gone crazy Senator Pat McCarran and the
great American Communist hunt is not
only this is not only a study of a man
sometimes overshadowed by fellow Irish
immigrant Joe McCarthy but also a
history of an era
Michael uborrow will speak for 20 or 30
minutes followed by a
question-and-answer session during which
we ask you to please use the audience
mic located right there and then we
happy to sign books afterwards so please
join me in welcoming mr. Ybarra well
thank you very much I should say first
of all that my book Washington gone
crazy is not a study of current events
though I think as I go along that some
of you might see a few unfortunate
parallels between the 1950s and this
current period and American history well
Washington gun-crazy is foremost a
biography of Senator Patton Karen who
was a Democrat from Nevada most people
don't remember him very well these days
if you fly into Las Vegas you've
probably been through McCarran
International Airport but most people
going to Las Vegas for whatever reason
seem to have their minds on something
other than political history well
McCarran is important because primarily
I think of the times in which he lived
through and the way he made his mark
upon those times and the period I'm
talking about is generally remembered as
the McCarthy period named for the
phenomenom of McCarthyism which is named
after Senator Joe McCarthy whom most
people remember
for no other reason than for the
phenomenon but what I attempt to do in
this book is to disentangle McCarthy
from McCarthyism and placed in the
context of longer events and my time
horizon actually stretches back to the
New Deal where I see sort of the
formative political divisiveness that
eventually boils over into what we
remember is McCarthyism well I'll start
by actually telling you a little bit of
the background of Pat McCarran and work
up to the McCarthy period Pat McCarran
was born in Reno in 1876 he was the son
of illiterate Irish immigrants and he
spent most of his youth very well
isolated on a farm down the Truckee
River from Reno really only people he
came in contact with in any consistent
basis were his mother and father's only
child and occasionally they had seasonal
seasonal help on the farm but we can't
really grew up very much without
learning to play with others and in fact
he never would learn to play well with
others
he started schools five years later than
he should have his father kept him back
on on the ranch because well he was
cheap labor so when he did start school
in the nearby town of Sparks he was
consequently five years older than all
of his peers and as I indicated he was
not naturally given to compromise in
fact really his life can best be
understood as operating two modes one
was opposition and the other was
domination and again and again you see
this four first two-thirds laugh hovers
mostly in opposition
well McCarran went to the University of
Nevada at Reno I was a good student but
had to drop out of school around his
junior year because his father had an
accident on the farm could no longer
work Karen was forced to leave school
and take over the family business which
was mostly sheep herding so McCarran
became
and he spent a couple years grazing she
pined to the Sierras but he really had a
burning desire to make himself something
more than that so at the end of each day
when he was done in the Sheep trail he
would put the flock to bed build a
campfire crack his saddlebags and take
outlaw books and he taught himself law
around the campfire passed the bar
became an attorney a defense attorney in
Reno mostly and he was actually a great
defense very very passionate very
dedicated to his clientele he would
represent accused abortionist became a
divorce lawyer you know Reno obviously
was the capital of quickie divorces in
America I quickie divorce in those days
required six weeks of residency so he
actually shot into a national
controversy at one point when he
represented Mary Pickford she wanted to
divorce her husband who Shaq actually
hadn't seen in years but they were still
married on paper so McCarran took cared
the divorce and it became something of
national scandal when she got divorced
one day and a couple days later married
Douglas Fairbanks Jr well what kind of a
successful lawyer and a good one but
it's not really what he wanted to do he
really wanted to get to Washington to
write laws instead of arguing about
other people's so for years he ran for
the Senate and he was never very
successful never he got very far largely
because the Democratic Party in Nevada
was controlled by a political machine
that McCarran couldn't get along very
well with no surprise if you know
anything about his temperament which is
it was quite cantankerous
and would often put principle above
magnetism one of his Senate primary
campaigns is an entire platform
consisted of opposition to the World
Court which was an issue that no one in
Nevada cared anything about at all so
his caddy as he went nowhere but finally
in 1932 the Democratic machine nominated
him or allowed him to be nominated for
the Senate that year
largely because they thought he would
lose and it's hard to remember at the
time that you know the Great Depression
was in its fourth year and you knows one
of the low points of American history
and you know many people look like
capitalism was not succeeding that
Democratic liberal capitalism was
actually something with failure compared
to perhaps alternative forms of
governance some people pointed to
Hitler's Germany or Stalin's Russia as
maybe more efficient ways to manage
modern economies and so you know it was
a quite a surprise when McCarran was
actually elected and so he goes to
Washington in 1933 on the coattails of
Franklin Roosevelt well the two of them
show up in Washington the same week and
by the end of the week
they're on opposite sides of one of the
second piece of the New Deal program
actually and so you know once again
McCarran didn't play well with others
now he supported enough of New Deal that
he could keep getting elected in Nevada
and he was ultimately elected to the
Senate four times you know McCarran was
against what he viewed as the New Deal
socialistic leanings except when that
involved bringing money to Nevada which
he was very eager to seek and quite
successful at that at one point the New
Deal gave more money per capita to
Nevada than any other state in the Union
and so McCarran continued to oppose much
of the New Deal however on ideological
grounds he was in a conservative wing of
the Democrats and Roosevelt was really
reinventing or you know American
democracy is creating modern welfare
state involved in federal government and
things that it had never considered its
business before things like you know
preventing children from working you
know giving people over you know
compelling companies to pay people for
the amount of time they actually worked
providing disability and old-age
pensions you know basically everything
that we assume
to be the government's job these days
was created by Roosevelt during the 30s
well you know McCarran spent most of the
30s in opposition to to the New Deal and
by this time we're about halfway through
the book but the core of the book is
really the second half
it starts in about the end of World War
two
now tremendous just come into the White
House after the death of Roosevelt and
McCarran has just come into the
chairmanship of the Senate Judiciary
Committee and now Truman and Roosevelt
should have gotten along fairly well
they were both people from small towns
roughly the same age had some smaller
temperaments actually they were both
somewhat anti-establishment resentful of
the eastern liberals even though Truman
was very much of a liberal at heart he
actually disdained what he called the
professional liberals and by that he
really meant sort of you know East Coast
Ivy League types they know the kind that
tended to dominate government in those
days you know McCarran shared these
antipathies but in practice the two of
them actually probably hated each other
as much as any politicians have hated
each other in Washington and that hatred
really drove a lot of what happens over
the next decade or so and Mackerras
position was very speck in on paper
because he has determined the district
committee was really in a position where
he could exercise an enormous amount of
power now under the seniority system
before it was reformed in more recent
decades a chairman of a committee had
basically untrammeled authority for
matters before his committee so if in
mccarran's case that's the district
committee 40% of all legislation in the
Senate had to pass through that
committee so McCarran couldn't outright
kill any bill that he didn't
but any bill that came into his
committee that he felt strongly about
had very little chance of actually
getting out of his committee and getting
to the floor unless he was satisfied by
some sort of horse trade or more often
there's some sort of abject capitulation
by one of his Senate colleagues on some
other matter that mattered even more to
him McKenna was also in the position to
control patronage through this committee
now any senator who wanted to nominate a
crony or an ally to the federal bench
the name of a judge makes him a federal
marshal or a US Attorney in their state
had to get that nomination through
mccarran's committee if the president
wanted to name an attorney general that
nomination had to go to McClaren's
committee so you know on paper that was
a lot of power and practice McCarran was
absolutely ruthless in wielding that
power so he turned it off quite soon
into one of the most powerful senators
that really Washington had ever seen and
he also had another lever of power which
was the Senate Appropriations Committee
which he was the chairman of the
subcommittee that controlled the budgets
for the Justice Department at the State
Department and a few other departments
so and we'll see later on how McCarran
managed to manipulate all these things
in in tandem so that in fact you know he
had control over legislation or include
Congress control over the people who
implemented many of these laws and a
great deal of influence even within the
White House bureaucracy of the
department's following these laws
implementing them well the first time
that McCarran and Truman really clashed
came in the aftermath of World War two
when Europe was awash in refugees you
know the war was one of the great
humanitarian crises of the modern era
and you know obviously the Holocaust was
enormous I mean tragedy that left
millions homeless in its way but there
were other refugees as well they were
all generally referred to as displaced
persons at the time now Truman the
Democratic leadership in the Republican
leadership and remember the Democrats
controlled both houses of Congress at
the time all agreed that America should
take war refugees and resettle them in
the country and legislation was duly
introduced to the effect McCarran
seriously more or less suggested that
they'd be resettled in Alaska
well that was an obvious non-starter
before the political pressure on both
sides of the aisle for in a legislation
immigration legislation so what McCarran
did then was to effectively stall the
bill for the better part of two years at
one point when it looked like he was
going to have to take the bill out of
his committee and bring it to the floor
for a vote
he announced suddenly that he was going
to take a three week fact-finding tour
to Europe three months later he came
back to the country now and meantime
he's gallivanting around Europe for 90
days instead of 21 days and he's doing
things like more or less opening up
diplomatic relations with Franco and
Spain now bear in mind that well for one
thing he's not a diplomat and he's not
even on the Foreign Relations Committee
Truman is trying to isolate Franco at
the time because well Spain is a fascist
fascist country and the war was supposed
to be about fighting fascism but to
McCarran the salient characteristic of
Franco was that he was an anti-communist
and you know had shown what he would
actually do the Communists in his
country which is pretty much killed them
and so Karen started a sort of a
reproach along with Franco's Spain that
against Truman's expressed wishes and
the express policy of the United States
actually wound up becoming
diplomatic faint accompli eventually a
Frank will take it back into the UN he
once said the rest of the world needs
Spain more than Spain needs the rest of
the world and eventually under the Cold
War by polar pressures you know that
turned out to be true the West did
recognize Franco and accept fascist
fascists Spain is a member in the
international community well you know so
at one point you pierson that column was
referred to me Karen is the senator from
Spain other people called him the
senator from Formosa and in Taiwan
because of his advocacy of the
nationalist regime there even after
they've been driven off the main man but
we'll get to that in a minute
so McCarran running around Europe having
a pretty good time he goes all over the
place meets the Pope asked for a few
favors for his family he had two
daughters were nuns and he wasn't shy of
asking even the Pope for a you know a
little poll and he eventually returns
home and stalls a little while longer
but eventually the immigration
legislation has passed European refugees
will get to resettle in America so they
that well three months later McCarran
passes the McCarran Internal Security
Act of 1950 which essentially spiked
immigration legislation with a host of
security provisions many of which
prevented refugees from resettling even
refugees who had cleared the security
provisions previously found themselves
suddenly back at square one you know
they had to meet a whole host of greatly
increased requirements to come to
America in one case a trainee in refuge
either I read about in the book got the
news he and his family were not going to
be able to come without reapplying and
starting all over again and he responded
by hanging himself well about this time
Joe McCarthy gives a speech in Wheeling
West Virginia which is considered the
start of McCarthyism and
history books most historians actually
allude to the fact that it had been
going on for several years but this
speech is kind of a focal point and you
know historians need some place to start
the story so usually the speech is is
granted that distinction
McCarthy basically said that the State
Department is full of commies and Truman
was unwilling or unable to do anything
about that and this made him famous and
it caused really a firestorm of
controversy in from the next five years
McCarthy's was in the press more than
any one except for Truman and then
Eisenhower when he became president so
McCarthy had a you know developed an
enormous buzz and it really became
synonymous with the cause of zealous
anti-communism the point to this book
however is to place that into context
and so the context here is that
conservatives and especially
conservative Democrats had been battling
the Liberals in Washington throughout
the 30s and 40s and at this point there
everyone who is anti-communist I'm gonna
grant them you know a a wave run kind of
read their soul so you know I assume
everyone's sincere about it not but it
doesn't mean they're not opportunistic
at the same time and it's clear that the
Conservatives really did use the issue
of communists in Washington as a club
with which to beat the crap out of the
Liberals at the time so you know the use
of a political issue such as subversion
might sound familiar to some who
remember this recent election
well McCarthy was as I say the most
famous proponent of this sort of
hardcore anti-communist view but he
really didn't accomplish a whole lot he
would make a speech and say something
outrageous and get a lot of press for it
he would say someone like
owen lattimore an asian scholar was the
top soviet espionage agent in america
then he would forget about Lattimore
move on and make some other accusation
and would get another headline well
McCarran didn't forget one of the things
that McCarran did after his Internal
Security Act was passed was he created a
committee in the Senate to monitor how
it was implemented so quite honestly
didn't trust Truman to implement his law
after all he was only the president so
McCarran formed the Senate Internal
Security subcommittee and the first
thing it did was it spent 18 months
investigating on that and more now whom
McCarthy aide you know accused of being
a Soviet spy
Lattimore wasn't a spy he had been in
the 30s wood used to be called a fellow
traveler at some point he had been
ideologically sympathetic towards the
Soviet Russia by the 40s and 50s it
probably moved somewhat to the center if
not to the right but this didn't really
matter in 1949 China had gone communist
now this was the biggest country on
Earth largest population in the world is
suddenly a communist nation and the US
had been aiding the nationalist regime
Mao somehow managed to win to people
like Truman and his Secretary of State
denaturants it was just because the
Chinese decided to you know this was
what how things were going to be or they
had a civil war and the Nationalists
were corrupt and inept enough to lose it
to conservatives of McCarran and
McCarthy's elk that didn't really
explain anything you know how could the
you know nationalists lose with the aid
of the greatest power in the world the
u.s. well you know it had to be
treachery someplace and it was probably
treachery in the State Department and
Owen Lattimore had been an advisor to
the State Department so McCarran
launched this probe that lasted 18
months into Latin War the State
Department
and it was really a incredibly thorough
which not to say fair procedure that in
ended up in snerling people from a whole
host of universities and departments in
the government involved the CIA one of
the people who was caught up in this was
George Kennan architect of the
containment policy who found himself
eased out of government partly due to
his subpoena before the McCarran
Committee Latimer found himself charged
with perjury
not any substantive issues but because
he had trouble remembering the things
that had happened 15 years earlier and
Truman wrote a letter to one of his
attorney generals saying that well if
anyone deserves to be charged with a
felony because what this committees been
doing it's not Latin more as obviously
referring to mccarran's other witnesses
who were accused of being committing
perjury but McCarran was only interested
in pursuing perjury among those accused
of helping the Soviets not those who
were anti-communist well the Attorney
General under great pressure from
McCarran did indict Lattimore was thrown
out by the courts McCarran pressured
another attorney German to re-indict in
Latin more which happened thrown out
again but I mean this gives you some
idea of mccarran's tenacity his
relentlessness and actually his you know
amount of power he had getting actually
you know Truman's Attorney General to do
his bidding columnist Murray Kempton
referred to McCarran has the de facto
attorney general of the US during the
last years of the Truman administration
Truman himself called McCarran simply an
sob Paul Douglas one of the kinder
hearted people to serve in the Senate
referred to him as simply an evil man
well there was also the 1952 McCarran
Walter Immigration Act which is really
mccarran's legacy
and that in effects enacted something of
a ideological wall around America it
made it much harder for people with any
radical associations to get visas to
visit the company the country it
resolved in quite a few people being
arrested who had been citizens or
naturalized citizens for years and
deported prevented people from getting
passports who were American citizens but
wanted to travel abroad if they fell
afoul of mccarran's a litmus test and
the act was implemented by the State
Department there are letters and that I
quoted in a book from some truman aid
aides complaining that there's State
Department bureaucrats at the middle
levels were following mccarran's wishes
and not Truman's wishes so you know she
once again the way McCarran managed to
sort of skillfully create a law and then
oversee its implementation and you know
the immediate effect of this was that
cruise ships would pull into New York
Harbor people would get off and
immigration authorities would find their
names on a list promptly put them on a
tugboat headed towards Ellis Island
where they were detained pending
deportation and they were told that you
know they had violated the law although
exactly how they had violated the law
was not something they were privy to so
they were allowed to contest their
deportation but not told what the
grounds were for deportation so in
effect you know if you were turned away
by the law you're recourse was to either
rot on Ellis Island or give in and go
home and you know in some cases there
were communists caught by this or warmer
fascists but in many cases people like
German war brides who had were trying to
join their husbands in the u.s. were
caught up in this a delegation of German
students who had come to America to
study how democracy works found
themselves stuck on Ellis Island with an
all-expense open-ended trip there well
you know I can go on and on because
McCarran
we did he you know he he was in his 70s
by this time but he had an enormous
amount of energy and more than that an
enormous rancor and the means to really
vent his rage against liberalism and you
know wasted no effort to ever do that
I think I'll read you a little bit from
this but I'll put that into from the
book but I'll put that in the context by
mentioning the 1952 Senate race which
tells you a lot about McCarran it's a
high point of his power and he's one
newspaperman Hank Green's button said
the McCarran was sixth in seniority in
the Senate but first in power the
progressive magazine that year said that
McCarran and Truman had been battling
all year long and mccarran's been
winning every fight so you know he's
really at the peak of his game and well
what happens is there's a newspaper in
Las Vegas the only newspaper in his
state that actually is critical of
McCarran and one day the newspaper finds
that all of its advertisers all of its
which were casinos suddenly decided on
the same morning to cancel their
advertising well the newspaper man Hank
green spun didn't think this was a
coincidence so one of the things he did
he sued macaron is became something of a
cause celeb across the country and so
McCarran found himself on their
disposition being deposed by lawyers and
under oath he was asked about some
alleged friends of his like Bugsy Siegel
the mobster who basically built Las
Vegas in the end of the war McCarran
claimed never to have met him FBI
wiretaps proven otherwise but more
importantly what happened was that
Greenspan championed a insurgent
Democrat who was running for the Senate
that year in Nevada who was running for
the junior Senate seat McCarran had been
grooming
protege of his for this same spot and
everyone thought that mccarran's man
would win well McCarran man actually
lost so what did McCarran do he
supported the Republican contender for
the Senate seat who with mccarran's
backing won the Democrats that year lost
the Senate by one seat so essentially
McCarran in a fit of pique and rage
brought down his own temple upon himself
he lost his Judiciary Committee
chairmanship managed however to maintain
much of his power in the Washington Post
it was almost as powerful after the
election it was before because even as
the minority member of the committee he
managed to intimidate and cower the
Republican chairman Dwight Eisenhower
compared arguing with McCarran as to
being like beating on an anvil with a
sponge well he kind of lived 2 years
longer and he dropped dead on the
campaign trail shortly after giving yet
another speech denouncing the Communist
Minnis and about a month after he died
McCarthy was censured by his colleagues
in the Senate this is fall 1954 and so
that's where the book really ends with
mccarran's death in the car keys Center
and I'll read a little bit about the
1952 Senate election as I write about it
in the chapter late in the book
now this chapter starts with a couple of
quotes the first comes from Harry Truman
we came to the great gambling and merits
destruction hill known as Nevada Teleco
to look at it from the air it is just
that hell on earth there are tiny green
specks in the landscape where dies
roulette crooked poker and gambling
thugs thrive such places should be
abolished and so should Nevada it never
should have been made a state a country
a county in the great state of
California would be too much of a civil
existence for that dead and sinful
territory think of that awful sinful
place having two senators and
congressmen in Washington and Alaskan
Hawaii not being represented it's a
travesty in our system and a disgrace to
free government well I think you can
read into that perhaps Truman's feelings
about the senior senator from Nevada the
second quote is from the columnist Drew
Pearson who lunched with government of
Pitman he gave me a long story of the
despotism of senator McCarran it was so
shocking that it was hard to believe
more like a story happening in Russia
and the chapter is called the dead and
it starts during an unusually cold
winter at 51 Chevy ku pulling a trailer
crawled in to Las Vegas the young couple
in the front seat had $7,000 in a plan
and when of agus this wasn't exactly
unheard of but town met chillings plan
was more audacious than most you wanted
to run from the US Senate against Pat
McCarran when the McCarran wasn't up for
reelection for another four years
so McLean a Washington journalist with
no political experience was only tied to
the stake was the fact that his wife had
been born there had to settle for
running against my parents protege and
former law partner alan bible no
candidate invader mclean recalled within
the past decade had ever run for higher
office with even a hope of making
incredible showing unless he had behind
him mclaren political machine a good
deal of millionaire gambling money and
nevada birth i had none of these the
post-war boom nevada finally had more
people in the square miles but just
barely
mclean and his wife planned to spend
eight months and their life savings
driving around nevada going door-to-door
across the state
bypassing the newspapers that printed
only what McCarran wanted them to print
taking his candidacy straight to the
voters don quixote new trailer people
called him that's the boys a gunner
surprised a lot of people his
father-in-law johnny did grazia said
even in las vegas couldn't find someone
to take that bed across the room the
phone kept ringing it was March 24th
1952 and Hank green spun the owner and
publisher of the son was pounding away
with two fingers at his typewriter
riding his column from the next day's
paper railing against the prominent
brothel in the outskirts of town since
the town was Las Vegas he might as well
have complained about the dawn but for
Greenspun 43 was nothing if not [ __ ]
Asia's standing trim just over six feet
tall they brawler's nose and a mouthful
of gold teeth usually clamp down on a
cigar Greenspun could have passed as a
former boxer
indeed he approached journalism like a
barroom fight
he threw words like punches and he wrote
to her ignored the ringing Norman white
papers ad manager walk daughter
we're in trouble he said in 30 minutes
he explained three big casinos had
pulled the business from the Sun the
Thunderbird El Rancho the last frontier
White's phone rang again
Greenspan followed him back to the desk
the Flamingo canceled her dad's then the
morning got really bad another eight
casinos walked away from the Sun almost
a third of the paper's revenue had
disappeared before lunch not a single
large casino on the strip were downtown
wanted anything to do with the
publication Greenspun rushed out of his
office on Main Street jumped into his
red convertible and drove south for a
few blocks until the road merged into
the strip
another mile Greenspan reached last
frontier Las Vegas seconds casino
emotive court now did it up as Western
theme park beyond that slunk glass
casino on the strip were taught and
signed topped by pink bird towered above
a low-rise building flamingo there
glowed at night and soft pink neon
six years earlier when greenspan first
drove down this road there were only two
motels and fewer than 200 rooms on this
trip he came to town to promote a
racetrack
instead he round up as a flack publicity
agent from ups or mobster bugsy siegel
whose Flamingo set off the building boom
this year the strip was gaining another
500 rooms and would be nearly enough for
the prosperous hordes of tourists
decades to pound in the decade the
pound's population tripled and Las Vegas
showed no signs slowing down Grinspoon
wheeled left and pulled into her
driveway wrapping around and fountains
bringing water into the air the center
stood a tower topped by a cloud shaped
sign supposed to be an artist palette
proclaiming Wilbur Clark's desert in
actual it was more that leaps as desert
in Clark ran out of money during
construction had to give up
three-quarters of a stake to Mars die
elites got his start in the dry cleaning
business in Michigan but found his real
meaty a as a rum runner and casino
operator in the sunny years after the
war died elites was one of many who
discovered that moving to Las Vegas
could change him overnight from the
criminal to businessman the old way of
doing things died hard when boxer Sonny
Liston tried to pick a fight with
deletes the casino owner didn't blink if
he hit me [ __ ] he said you better kill
me because if you don't I'll make one
phone call and be dead in 24 hours
Liston kept his fist at his side and
tough times that leads like to say call
for tough people Greenspan went in the
front door of the desert in the DI
everyone called it straight up the back
he knew his way around he had put his
savings into the casino and worked as
its PR man only to find like his friend
Robert Clark those role was being
reduced in significance
Clark was content to see his name on the
marquee Greenspan went out and bought a
newspaper instead putting his opinions
in the front page every day where I
stand beans man called his column behind
the casino Greenspan found elites
talking for another architect about an
18-hole golf course they were building
the leads loved golf he also loved guns
subject is known to registered seven
guns with
Clark County Sheriff's Office - FBI
noted and therefore should be considered
armed and dangerous what's going on
Greenspun interrupted you should know
delete said why did you have to attack
the old man what business it is is it of
the Desert Inn or any other hotel what I
printed my paper being spun and asked
put it in a terrible position that leach
replied you know as well as I do that we
have to do what he tells us you know
that you got us our licenses and if we
don't go along you know what will happen
to us when deletes first came to the
state in 1914 and he couldn't get a
gambling license something usually only
slightly hard to get it in Nevada than a
driver's license McCarran took an
interest in his new constituents problem
however and Elliott got his license then
in 1951 McCarran saved Nevada's gambling
industry from federal taxation now the
senator wanted to industry to squash his
loudest critic in the state that lets
knew who to put his money on he was a
good investor a friend recalled Moe
never went against the tables behind the
men the Desert Inn sign rose above a
three storey tower the tallest building
on the strip which held the sky bar a
favorite place for people to watch the
mushroom clouds and occasionally erupted
in the her horizon for a year the
federal government had been exploiting
atomic bombs at the Nevada Test Site 65
miles north e west of town in las vegas
the ground could shake and the sky turn
to fire someone would make book and how
long the world would last Greenspan
glared down at Dahl eats half a head
shorter a decade older he hated him
during the arab-israeli war Greenspun
had smuggled on us or Israel that leads
for the Arabs now the mobster was trying
to kill his newspaper a Las Vegas Sun
was approaching its second anniversary
they might not see a third
Greenspun stuck his fist into his
pockets if I hadn't he remembered I
probably would have used them at the
Thunderbird where the neon chicken both
Marquis bat-gas flames from its mouth
nude ice skaters cavorting in the
showroom and millionaire Howard Hughes
was a regular washing his on the shirts
in the sink there was always a booth
reserved McCarran and his suite waiting
for him
when McCarran asked for the check and
never came the casino knew how to treat
politicians but should one of its owners
was cliff Jones the state's lieutenant
governor whose idea of business dress
was a task invest cowboy boots who had
11 points in the casino Jones didn't
drink smoke or gamble but he made a good
living from those who did and he had
been a macaron supporters since the 1932
campaign before Jones was even old
enough to vote you make a good
lieutenant governor someday McCarran
told him he paid for law school by
working on Boulder Dam then opened an
office and the clothing store in Fremont
Street but most of his legal business
involved helping clients get gambling
license licensees and Jones soon
realized that taking a percentage of the
casino was more lucrative than billing
by the hour when the cleaning store
Bulow's office turned into the Pioneer
Club Jones took five points in the deal
at one time he had interest in seven
different casinos mostly at the
Thunderbird which opened in 1948 the
year after he became lieutenant governor
the twin endeavors made Jones a very
useful person to know in Las Vegas the
big juice people called him juice and
local parlance was ability to make
things happen in Nevada only McCarran
had more choose majority owner the
Thunderbird was Marion Hicks who went
from running a gambling boat off
California coast to building casinos in
Las Vegas and going 51 percent of the
venture Karen was fond of Hicks really
knows the game and he has a nice
personality said once in Las Vegas in
the 1950s lawmakers and law breakers
rubbed shoulders together if a
nonchalance remark will even for
Frontier boomtown Nevada had finally
found his true bonanza a gold mine that
can never be dug dry legal gab gambling
nearly a century after Brigham Young had
tried to claim Las Vegas for the Mormons
the town more closely resembled Sodom
and Gomorrah and Salt Lake City
Las Vegas was not yet 50 years old but
it was the fastest growing city of its
size in the US population jumped from
8,000 to 24,000 would jump to 64,000 in
another decade at the end of World War
II there were two casinos in mystery
before 1952 was over there'd be seven
and three blocks stretch of Fremont
Street downtown already housed the
densest concentration of the gambling on
the planet only three establishments
weren't casinos a drugstore which had
slot machines a bank and a 24-hour
western union office we give him what
they can't get in Grand Rapids said one
local businessman let me give it to him
24 hours a day
at first glance Las Vegas seemed too
good to be true like some sort of Mirage
shimmering in the desert palm trees
shaking pools like curved like a woman's
hips showgirls sunning themselves by day
mingling casinos at night cheap rooms
cheaper buffets piled high with shrimp
on ice and when the slices of prime beef
chilled rooms where you could watch
Frank Sinatra or Eartha Kitt or Liberace
no minimum no cover on Saturdays and
Sundays there was three shows a night
which meant you could see six stop acts
over a weekend all for free of course
nothing was really free conventioneers
might be greeted with a clanging bag of
25 silver dollars but if you left town
with much change jingling in the pockets
from the Gatlin of slot machines lining
the way out of the terminal McCarran
Airport which had been named after him
in 1942 the supermarkets that took
casino chips as cash Las Vegas was
growing rich any single ineluctable
proposition a house on average never
loses and Las Vegas was nothing but one
big house
Liberace might earn 50 grand a week for
playing the crowds and paid nothing but
ticket to the showroom thousands had to
funnel through casinos or slot machines
pulled in pennies and nickels and dimes
and quarters and so for dollars like
magnets but returned only a few pounds
on the ton and after a little more than
an hour of that version guests were
herded back into the casinos or die
stumbled let balls bounce blackjack
dealers to turn over each card like a
personal favor just to find a hotel
lobby you had to navigate a maze of
green felt tables and narrow passageways
of winking slot machines whatever a
casino spent an attractive try
that came back in waves of profit
multi-million dollar establishment paid
for himself in half a year single Casino
wore out 80 pairs of dice in a day the
promise of the strip was that its
casinos were somehow different in the
downtown gambling joins the gambling
gaming in the vernacular they wholesome
recreational activity to be enjoyed by
Americans in the post-war boom sort of
like television with odds the reality
was it was just the same sucker's game
just up his family entertainment I used
to be a star on Broadway Tallulah
Bankhead admitted from the stage the
sands where she was earning $20,000 a
week and now he see me reduced to his
shield for a gambling joint gambling was
changing Nevada Reno was still the
state's largest city but Las Vegas which
accounted for most of the gambling
business was catching up the population
men boats which meant power which too
was shifting southward but as riches
gambling was for casino owners the real
money was the skim the cash that gushed
into the counting rooms who never made
it into the official books that was the
real jackpot a source of untaxed wealth
is when it was human optimism and tell
ability but from McCarran there was
paradox behind this prosperity when he
settled into his booth at the t-birds
powwow room and the stakes came the
tabbed in the Karen was acutely aware
for all the visitors who shuffled
through the casinos that the state's
latest Bonanza was less to function
every real economies and the
exploitation of yet another extractive
industry taking rocks out of the earth
Sun during the vows of marriage taking
the coins out of the pockets of visitors
this was found that is sustained itself
for years in the Karen had struggled to
attract manufacturing spectacle commerce
to Nevada decade early had placed his
hopes and a magnesium plant outside of
town we're going to build a great
industrial senator Clark County he had
beamed 1947 but five years later when
the plant had been turned over to
private industry was employed fewer than
3,000 people less than half the number
at work in the casinos the only industry
and then it was really able to flourish
in the desert soils gambling Karen and I
our that industry in ways that he was
glad to declare any ways that he would
never know
which macaron then the Las Vegas boom
was both in a accomplishment to claim
credit for and a personal failure to
lament source of pride as well as a
Badgers saying I'm afraid erupt her
friend
we have blinkered our eyes to what is
the stronger form of economy and the
payrolls and legitimate businesses I
hope the time will come when the
financial structure of the state of
Nevada will not rest upon gambling I
hope the time will come when we point
with pride to industries of all kinds in
the state with payrolls that will
sustain the economy but that isn't today
Joe and it won't be tomorrow the day
would never come
I'll stop there and anyone has any
questions be happy to take him yes sir
you seem to disparage McCarran going to
Franco's Spain yet Roosevelt recognized
was the first president recognized
communist Russia and we had trade and
recognized Nazi Germany with Nazi
Germany we had trade and fastest Japan
it until almost World War two started I
mean what was the big deal about him
going to France well I mean I'm sorry to
Spain yeah good point
and I really wouldn't say that there's
any normative difference between some of
the countries of the US has had to deal
with over the years so I won't contest
your point I think if you have a
question if you can use the microphone
that would help
analogies with the present time are
unavoidable so let me just make a quick
one on my way to my question today
terrorism has become the Communist you
know the contemporary communism and we
can't help but look at the analogies now
what I'd like to ask is when McCarran
was you know exploiting the Communist
issue and and the only thing he had the
betta to have power was to be
anti-communist didn't matter anything
else was there an opposition like today
there is a press and there is opposition
and there are some people in Congress
who are trying to oppose this and
there's opposition to the Patriot Act
and so on so they don't have a free hand
but I kind of get the impression the way
you talked that McCarran had a free hand
that he just nobody stopped him where's
their opposition and what happened to
the opposition well I'm glad you asked
that there was quite a bit of liberal
opposition unfortunately from my
perspective it was pretty much useless
if you look at the way McCarran managed
to sort of steamroll his his laws and
policies across Washington in the 50s a
lot of it had to do with the fear that
was literally in the air remember that
in 1949 China became communist the
Soviets exploited an atomic bomb
suddenly schoolchildren in Nevada were
given dog tags so that their bodies
could be identified in the event of
World War 3 coming to Manhattan soon
perhaps so there was a tremendous amount
of fear and anxiety in the air a rather
brave band of distinguished liberals in
the Senate people like Paul Douglas
Herbert Herbert Lehman and they fought
really heroically at times against
McCarran and I chronicled in great
detail some of their battles
unfortunately they always lost
Truman kept vetoing mccarran's laws
vetoes were overridden almost black
Kamlesh acclamation in Congress there
was 1951 of the years that I devote a
lot of attention to was an election year
and it was not a good thing to go on
record against opposing anti-communist
legislation that year so yes there was a
great deal of opposition I mean it came
from the White House which was you know
controlled both houses of Congress but
the temper at the times was such that
public sentiment was quite alarmed and
the majorities of both houses
continually supported McCarran in
McCarthy's style of anti-communism
McCarran have any sense of irony that he
was sponsoring anti-immigrant
legislation and yet he was the son of
immigrants himself not really during his
trip around Europe when he was delaying
the immigration refugee bill he popped
over to Ireland to visit the ancestral
village of his parents who had fled
Ireland in the 19th century from the
potato famine and gambled everything on
moving to the new world and starting new
lives
he got quite teary-eyed visiting his
relatives and realizing what his parents
had sacrificed so that he could have a
better life then he went back to refugee
camps in Germany and didn't get very
weepy when refugees would present their
stories to him questions Lyndon Johnson
was not Minority Leader but I think what
George leader during part of the time at
the McAra does your book touch on any
relationship to how he reacted to him
that's one the second one is the Joe
McCarthy we know he supported Jill
Kennedy we know he supported Joe
McCarthy financially to a certain extent
as he may have anything to do with
McCarran at all well Joe Kennedy I
didn't find any thing about him
supporting McCarran
be surprised he had the macaron papers
aren't complete they're they're very
rich but I have a feeling that when his
family vetted them before turning them
over to the University Archives that
they removed anything that would have
been too juicy as far as your first
question what was that again Johnson
okay yes yes yes Johnson was a wellness
McCarran says at one point as a young
man who someday might make something of
himself
Johnson at one point when he was running
for the position as a majority leader
sent an aide to every person in the
Senate trying to find out how are they
going to vote on a particular bill
because Johnson became famous for being
able to vote peak and he picked eight
predict the outcome of any any
legislation really and part of his
legend that he cultivated very
assiduously well the only Senate there
from whom he got no response essentially
was McCarran McCarran sent his aide back
with a message saying don't ever come to
this office again know the answer do we
know how Johnson voted on the internal
Securities Act and the McCarran Walters
act that was just before see the vote in
1950 I'm not sure Johnson was there for
that 148 right but I mean I don't
remember if he was actually there for
the vote or not so I don't remember how
he voted response the money of the
gentleman's questions I think you should
be pointed out to get a feeling of what
the times were like the Hubert Humphrey
who was one of my personal heroes Hubert
Humphrey was the one who introduced the
bill to outlaw the Communist Party which
passed by the way yesterday and it was
Harry Truman who instituted the loyalty
oath before McCarthy of required of all
of all government employees which gives
you a taste of what what it was like
even before McCarthy came on the scene
right well that's a very good point and
basically you mention you liberal
contribution to
anti-communism and which is one of the
themes of this book actually I deal over
the course many years with the evolution
of liberal thinking towards communism
and Soviet Union in the thirties was as
trendy is it was almost acceptable to to
be quite radical I was pretty much the
high point of radical acceptability in
American politics and and later on it
was called the red decade the 50s was
obviously the anti red decade so
essentially what a good chunk of this
book is dedicated to doing is examining
in the context and how that changes from
the radical 50s is conservative from the
radical 30s to the conservative 50s and
you know McCarran is pretty much the
same during that period but the
zeitgeist changes quite a bit and he
goes from being in opposition during the
30s to being in domination in the 50s
and the liberal response to this changed
as well after World War two there was
such a thing as liberal anti-communism
bodied by organizations like the
Americans for democratic action who
believed that you know Stalin was as
evil as Hitler and both should be
opposed assiduously which is not always
the case during the 30s so you know
liberalism did change it was not static
and he evolved and in fact was at the
forefront of fighting the Cold War I
mean people like Harry Truman Dina
Johnson were very decidedly
anti-communist however McCarran and many
of the people on the right and
conservatives didn't believe that or
didn't give them credit for their
profession professions of anti-communism
and so you know a lot of it I think is
payback for it for the 30s when the
Conservatives had been really abused and
sickened by the way that the Liberals
sucked up to Stalin not all liberals of
course but so anyway you know I try and
examine the sort of generational shift
in American politics and you know I
think that's a major part of the story
here so
you know many of the things that I'm
sort of alluding to very briefly here I
do detail and you know quite a few pages
in the book anyone else okay I can
repeat your question anti-communism of
these two Irishmen due to the influence
of the Roman Catholic Church well that's
an interesting but quite complicated
topic and in a mccarran's case
particular and particularly he was a
Roman Catholic attended church regularly
became very friendly with Carmen
Cardinal Spellman visited the Pope and
so Amy it was it was a Catholic but on
the other hand two of his daughters
became nuns and this was not something
it was quite happy about and he spent
years trying to get his daughters
reassigned closer to Washington as well
they could be near him and eventually he
succeeded but his personal
correspondence he's often quite critical
of the church for I suspect because of
his personality what he was critical of
is that the church was vying for his
daughter's attention with him because he
really you know you know things like the
White House the Vatican I mean he really
was a person from an enormous eagle ego
and did not you know really tolerate any
any rivals there was one of his critics
once said that there were three parties
in Washington the Republicans the
Democrats and McCarran kratts and the
mechanic rats were a party of one but
because of its power it was a fairly
enduring party so the the church is an
interesting issue it's one that
unfortunately I wasn't able to really
tease out you know anything that I could
tell you other than how he felt about it
in any specific time you know the the
church was being li ante
communists you know what part that
played in mccarran's anti-communist I
think was probably secondary though to
his own sort of visceral loathing for it
well McCarthy was actually not that much
of a church group goer
I believe he he was Catholic
certainly culturally Catholic but was
not nearly as sincere as McCarran in his
anti-communism McCarthy was kind of
person who could give a fiery speech
denouncing the government and then turn
around and shake hands and want to go
out for a beer with the person he'd been
denouncing whereas McCarran really was
much more grudge holder who was consumed
with these issues you know what was it
like to deal with such a disagreeable
person over a long period of time good
question
well McCarran was interesting because I
before I started writing the book I'd
done most of the research or and I wrote
as research at the same time for some
chapters but you know I knew the story I
mean and I knew how it ended and you
what he had basically done but I
actually did find myself continually
surprised really what a bastard he could
be I mean I thought I knew because I
read this stuff I'd done the research
but then writing it out and chapters and
you know sometimes I found myself I
can't believe how persistent he was and
how he ultimately won this battle or
that battle so in a weird way I did
develop some admiration for some of his
qualities and abstract as a tenacity his
persistence his you know principled
opposition so you know I I compared in
the book watching McCarran make laws is
being like watching a shark on the hunt
you know it's it's not really an
edifying spectacle but it's kind of a
fascinating one
any other questions